this conversation my name is Michael
Dearing I teach in the design school and
I have the privilege of introducing you
to this panel of experts on startup
compensation and hiring before we get
into the content I want to do two things
one is I'm going to ask the panelists to
introduce themselves tell you why
they're fabulous people to give you
advice on this topic but I would love to
know who's in the audience so if you're
starting a company right now raise your
hand okay now if you're if you're
currently in a start-up and you're here
to get help or tactical advice on how to
how to get the best team together put
your hand up you've already got a
startup going okay and if you're not
really in any of those buckets you're
just curious about the topic okay a nice
mix a nice mix so maybe what we could do
is just tailor our conversation to the
to the to the groups that are here and
like I said it's a nice small room so
we're going to be able to have a
conversation and hopefully hopefully do
that so why don't we start now ask
Janice to kick us off with introducing
herself and why she's here so Janice
Robertson I'm currently with the
Mayfield fund which is a venture capital
firm here in wealth Sand Hill Road close
to Joe and I've been with Mayfield nine
years now and investing in a broad range
of sectors from communication software
wireless mobile and some consumer so
I've been in venture capital in a very
interesting time and seeing lots of
changes in the hiring market from so the
tail end of one bubble and going through
the times to lead us where we are today
prior to that I was at 3.com and palm
for a number of years here in the valley
having come over from Europe and sold my
company to 3com so I've gone through
many difference of hiring environments
from Europe to here which is very
different to the corporate world to the
startup environment so be pleased to
share my views with you on that and as I
was just talking to Beth one of the
things I think is really fascinating
today is as you're trying to recruit
younger people millennials plus
the the working environment is so
different and it's a question I think of
how we as investors recruiters really
adapt to some of the new people that we
want to attract as well so there's lot
of interesting things going on beyond
money and stock and all that right hi
I'm Beth Steinberg and I am an
organizational consultant in the valley
focusing on working with different
startups coaching leaders helping build
culture putting together performance
systems for companies including Mozilla
lynda.com Metacafe a lot lots of
companies in the valley and prior to
that I had a long background in HR
started my career at Nordstrom in in the
olden days and opened up the entire
Midwest region which was really like
opening lots of little startups small
stores you know all over the Midwest
that were doing from 50 to 100 million
dollars in revenue and we had to
literally hire 500 to a thousand people
for each of those stores and build the
culture and get everything going came to
the valley had jobs at hewlett-packard a
couple of startups that were not
successful which was a great learning
lesson for me went to Electronic Arts
and help them kind of move to the to the
digital age from console to digital
distribution and then I was the the
first head of HR at Facebook in the very
early days of Facebook when we only had
five million users and nobody really
knew who we were we had just moved from
just having schools into to letting non
universities sign on to Facebook was
there during a high growth period where
we went from 150 employees to about 400
plus employees in a year lots of changes
throughout that time period and lots of
lessons learned you know both about
things that really worked well and
things that I would do differently from
my experience and you know happy to
share all that with you and as janice
spoke about i think you know beyond all
of this kind of the importance of
building culture and finding the right
people and keeping the right people is
one of the mo
important things that you can focus on
as the leader as your as you're building
a company so lots lots of perspective on
that my name is Jonah Prensky I'm the
human capital partner at Sequoia Capital
I've been in this job since 2002 and
what does that mean
my focus is really to work across our
entire portfolio which is now a global
portfolio and help our companies with
everything that has to do with people so
pre investment that's more working with
my partners to figure out who are the
people that come along with these
business plans we receive every day and
help us success or these people that we
can work with and grow with and then I
spend majority of my time post
investment with in a windy I our VP of
Sales how much should you pay your
people when your day round company when
your be around company etc and
everything else that has to do with with
the human capital function before
joining Sequoia I was in Andy's line of
work I was an executive recruiter for a
firm called Russell Reynolds where I did
all work in the semiconductor and micro
electronics space I'm Andy price and one
of the managing partners of a company
with a terrible name called Schweiker
price malarkey in various the name of it
for hundreds of the firm but the history
of the company is pretty interesting in
my view we've been around since 1977 my
partner recruited for Joe's firm the CEO
of Cisco Systems and network appliance a
few other big players so our start our
DNA of our firm has always been getting
involved in formative formation stage
companies and helping these companies
who are on the edge of innovation in by
definition in new categories recruit
management from industries that aren't
obvious and so that's a fascinating
topic and if any of you ever figure out
the pattern among it all then tell me
but we about five been in the space for
about 16 years
I earned emerged with this firm I'm with
now and what we've done is we've built
one of the locked our top three largest
independent technology firms maybe in
the world certainly in the u.s. we're 30
people we do about 75 to 85 executive
searches a year and it's all board CEO
and
sea level or VP kind of projects and
about five years ago we thought when we
fired our governor in Sacramento over a
lousy energy policy I had an epiphany
and thought that the story of our time
was going to be energy and natural
resources so I switched my career from
technology and into energy and clean
technology and from then to now we've
done about a hundred and fifteen
searches in space ranging from
automotive components to solar to wind
and biofuels and chemicals and all kinds
of fascinating categories so what the
company does broadly speaking is my
partner's do social media internet
digital media related things some of the
other guys do semiconductor
infrastructure equipment comms wireless
you name it we're in the space and
90-odd percent of our clients are
venture-backed startups I'm pleased to
be here today and thank you all four of
you for showing up and and helping folks
understand the perspectives you've got
on building teams maybe since everybody
in the room was either currently running
a start-up or aspired to do that I'd
loved it go just go right down the line
and we'll start in reverse order with
Andy what's the one piece of advice
you'd have for somebody creating a team
from scratch that that you'd like to
pass on in this format yeah a good
timely question um my number one advice
well it's two there I do things I'm
gonna cheat a little bit I think one is
you gotta go find help and it's not
necessarily with a search firm or a bank
it's really with someone who's in an
industry who's grown a company before
and can mentor your company mentor you
personally and is a dispassionate third
party that can give you objective advice
for example if you're going to take
money from the institutional investors
which institutional investors are most
appropriate who's going to help you
who's more who's to oversubscribed to
actually give you the time of day they
may write you a check but then they may
end up being a bigger problem than an
asset I'd say start with Sequoia I'm not
just saying that cuz Joe's here or you
know Mayfield or someone with new money
no but Sears it
I said Oracle be like a Mayfield
somebody's got new money fresh capital
and a good reputation is an
institutional player or a company who is
very much dialed in to the space that
you're in and has some expertise that
they can lend so I guess the idea is
bring in a mentor who's a veteran kind
of presence either on the board or as an
adviser listen to a cross-section of
advice be thoughtful about that first
step you take into you know
capitalizing your company great advice
mr. d I just want to clarify the are you
talking more about who your partner
might be in establishing a start-up or
the first executive hire you bring that
board let's do both let's talk about
picking a partner picking a partner
first of all I think it's critical that
you have a partner I don't know how many
startups have really gotten off the
ground where there was just a single
founder I don't know if you guys have
many examples but I can't think of too
many and and in picking your partner I
think you got to pick somebody that has
the same ideals that you have and I
think you know you guys are all
entrepreneurs you know what it takes it
takes conviction it takes an incredible
amount of energy it takes resilience you
know a lot of people think it's just a
lot of fun to be in a start-up well it's
not all fun where people really
appreciate that you want to have
somebody that shares I think all those
attributes in terms of bringing on your
first executive that is really really
tricky and and I've heard numbers that
fifty percent don't make it I don't know
if that's accurate or not and so my
advice there would be kind of take your
time get good advice from your venture
firm or from whoever else your lawyers
can be very helpful and find people that
you know have the right experience you
have a lot of those same attributes you
know but but also you know somebody that
listens well and that you want to work
with you know sometimes people hire the
best resume as opposed to the the person
that fits the you know fits the
organization upfront so just a few folks
I agree with everything that Joe said
and I think it's it's really important
to hire somebody that is not in your
same image it's a quote from D Hawk that
said you know don't you know don't hire
somebody in your own image look to fill
your defecate deficits not duplicate
your strengths and you know we like
ourselves you'd like to hire people that
are similar than we are but I think from
a skillset perspective you really need
to get a different skill set than your
own I think from a value and integrity
perspective it's absolutely imperative
that you're aligned on on that piece of
it but look for somebody who can do
things that are different then then you
can do that may have a contrary opinion
than you do on things because I think
that's where you get the best answer and
as joe said it's it's it's really
important that you take your time with
it and really make the best decision you
know as you're growing a company those
first three or four leaders that you
hire really set the cultural tone for
the company and if you make a mistake
there it can really you know prevent you
from moving as quickly as you could have
if you if you made the right decision so
that's my advice the other thing too is
don't pretend as a leader that you know
things that you don't know you know I
think it's it's sometimes difficult to
admit we don't know things but nobody
knows everything and I think you need to
really seek out somebody who can help
you figure out those things that you are
not well-versed on yeah you know I think
the real phase it's very delicate is
when you got you know founding team
who's starting to grow the company and
realizes that they need to bring in you
know a professional if you like and so
that is a very sort of delicate sort of
time and I do think it is helpful to
have help whether it's from your
investor from someone who's got a human
capital saurian tation like Joe or
indeed from a recruiter that being said
I think even with a recruiter often
internal referrals are very helpful but
you can still put them into the pot but
you know having sort of a frame of
reference from
people you know can be very helpful when
you're bringing someone new into your
company and I think as a founder you
really need to be very open-minded at
the same time you really need to believe
that this person that you bring you on
board to share in your company is really
going to have similar values similar
dreams similar visions so I think the
key thing there is really taking time
take references work with other people
just really take sort of time about it
when you're starting to build up your
team one of the things that comes up a
lot is whether you recruit specialists
or generalists and there's probably a
combination of both it's another thing
to think about you know certainly when
you're talking about you know bringing
people in with certain engineering
skills you need two main expertise and
so on but one thing to think about is
you're building your team is that you
will adapt your business it's very very
few businesses end up being what they
start out to be so you do need people
who are not going to be focused on a job
description people who really want to
help you build the company so I think
you're really strong general generalists
yeah they would have some obviously
domain expertise as well can be very
important as well and and you know we
talked about getting the best that you
can you can get but at the same time
these issues of feeling you want to work
with that person feeling you can work
with that person feeling that you have
the same ethics work orientation goals
is really really important because it
can be you know it's a fabulous time
when you're starting out with a company
you get financing you starting to get
momentum but then you have to build the
company and you start to build bring in
people who were not part of the founding
team it's just sort of there's a lot of
tension there so you really need to
spend time on it and be thoughtful
great advice I'll see I'll keep seeding
the conversation with one more question
and off my list and then we'll open it
up to everybody a lot of people choose
the early stage or the venture career
path because they want to be owners they
either as founders or as as smaller own
smaller share owners but owners
nonetheless how do you think about the
problem of dividing equity both between
founders and between those first few
hires and what rules of thumb have you
seen people
used that was that really made a
difference on the plus side and also
what are some of the watch outs that
you've seen in either in your portfolio
companies or companies that you've been
a part of dividing equity is probably
one of the hardest choices you have to
make we're going to start here yeah and
anybody who wants to just jump in we see
about a hundred we see probably in
aggregate about a hundred and eighty to
two hundred and fifty startups a year so
we'll look at things and if we look at
them as a potential client and we think
it's got a hairy cap table or something
along those lines we think the company
is wired for failure and a lot of that
has to do with exactly what Mike was
talking about it's that you have you
know people have expectations the
entrepreneurs expectations these days
are in some cases still a little high
especially in the energy space they
think it's a frothy space and it is and
it's been over invested in and things
like that and so there's a there's a
bubble aspect to it and I think the
thinking about budgeting equity for the
long haul
can you maintain a 20% employee pool
right so 20% of cap table should be in
my view set aside from management in the
employees if it's any less than that I
really think your employees are being
there for the wrong reasons they're
going to need more cash or whatever and
that's a to me you should really always
try and maintain and protect that
employee equity base founders we
typically see end up at liquidity at
between a Joe would know way better than
I would but on my frame of reference is
about three to seven percent at
liquidity for the CEO for the for the
CEO and then usually the founders are
somewhere within striking distance of
the CEO and then the management ends up
with you know half a percent of maybe
one and a half percent range at that
liquidity again so you start so you say
okay we're starting here what are our
assumptions in terms of time capsule
we're going to need and you work back
from that and budget that equity the
same way you would budget cash and be
very and have that cap table in front of
you at all times
understanding that equity distribution
and quickly a funny example in the
beginning of Cisco my partner was doing
a VP of Sales search and the CEO before
that guy was replaced came said to the
VP of Sales hey I'm gonna give you our
sales guy said how much how much equity
you're saying sizes four point nine so
the sales guy that he was trying to hire
said well I'm gonna get
percent of Cisco Systems turns out it
was 4% set aside for the whole
management team and the board had a
pretty pretty toxic reaction to this
this is so ancient history of insuring
anybody here but the point is is don't
be awkward or clumsy with the
distribution of that equity because it
is your most precious resource in my
personal view or one of them a few other
kind of related comments number one just
plan ahead you know don't start your
company with with a de minimis option
pool it just creates lots of problems
and really really plan ahead figure out
okay we're going to hire three types of
engineers and here's the basis of equity
we're going to give them and be willing
to crack the code occasionally but try
not to often a typical mistake companies
make is in their first executive they
going to bring on board and this is
prompted with titles and with equity
you've got an EVP and he wants four
points of the company and then every
subsequent hire becomes a nightmare
because people talk people find out so
that's one lesson another one is don't
skimp with equity I think everybody in
the company from the receptionist
through the CEO all should get equity in
the company we emphasize equity more
than cash you know try and keep salaries
low but I think you guys all are aware
of that so a couple points yeah I mean I
agree with all that and I you know you
guys are more probably more verse on it
in totality than I am but I think in
general don't get too greedy yourself
because nobody can do it on their own
your team is so important to you and you
know I think it's such a rewarding
feeling to know that you know the
receptionist's got equity and made you
know at Cisco the receptionist has your
own plate now you know I think to me
that is such a story of Silicon Valley
and you know such a great result of how
things work in the valley so don't get
too greedy yourself the difference
between you know fifteen percent and
thirteen percent is so minimal when it's
you know when it's large numbers and you
really need to keep that team engaged
and retained and you know in a start-up
equities the way that you do that I
think on the other hand though don't
over focus on it because you know you
don't want people coming into your
company only be
they think they're going to get rich I
mean you want people to believe in the
team and believe in the product and know
they're going to work really really hard
this is this might take ten years or
more so don't overemphasize it too much
you know and you'll really have to
screen and make sure that people want
the right things when they're when
they're coming to your company yeah a
couple of points I would make there so
so first of all I think as as the
managers of a company or the CEO of a
company it as best as you can it's great
to keep the interests of everybody
aligned so obviously you know stocks can
be distributed in different amounts but
really bringing everybody together and
getting everybody feeling they're part
of the company is really important the
other thing that's important it can be
difficult to do is to keep investors and
management aligned and and sometimes and
you alluded to it cap structures can get
too complicated and and particularly for
companies been around for a while and so
I will I personally like to keep things
quite simple because I think that's the
best way to keep everybody aligned but
sometimes your take cap structures can
get complicated with preferences and so
on and sometimes those structures can
compensate for people wanting overly
high valuations and things like that so
I think working with the team that you
have around you with your investors you
know with your legal counsel and so on
keeping it as simple and as aligned as
possible is really really important and
I've worked for a company where you know
when stock is distributed and the
company is doing well and everybody
benefits it's just a phenomenal thing
and people work harder you know and they
feel great and obviously their financial
benefits but you also feel really good
about being part of this sort of winning
organization and it's just a great thing
now on the other hand there are some
challenges today because the liquidity
market is not as good as it was some
years ago and so you know it can take
time for you to get to that exit point
and this time can end up leading to more
complicated cut tables and so on and so
on exit you can get all sorts of
complications in terms of carve outs and
things
that so again try to minimize that but
also intensive area by sector and I know
obviously is right we try to get people
focus on the equity component but you
know we're seeing now in this valley I
think across a lot of companies that
there's a relatively stronger emphasis
on the cash and bonus component of
compensation you know from a CEO down so
people looking for more cash higher
bonuses contracts and things like that
and when I came here from Europe it was
sort of at will you know risk its you
know and and and this is what the valley
is all about and I'm seeing a little
more structure come into these
compensation environments and also this
you actually are seeing some people who
are sort of okay I've been working at
this startup for years and now my kids
go into college and my wife's putting
pressure on me maybe I should go back
and work for Cisco for a couple of years
to pay for the college fees or something
you know because the exits not coming
but you know I think that you know I
mean sort of giving you anecdotes to
make a point but I do think there's some
sort of change here that we have to sort
of think about with the exit environment
you know taking some time in certain
sectors all great points I might add one
best practice to think about that I've
seen since a lot of you are in positions
where you're going to be hiring younger
folks who might not have actually had
the experience of being shareholders in
the company they worked out before I've
seen some founders take some really
valuable and worthwhile time out to
explain how does a cap table work who
owns what and why and you might not get
down to the to the Nats ass of detail on
who has how many shares but you might
just take the time to explain what does
it mean to be an owner and what's the
difference between preferred and common
and how does vesting work it is amazing
how many people don't actually know and
would love it if you would tell them how
it all works mechanically you'll be
doing them a huge favor probably saving
yourself a lot of questions to my boys
Atlantic's out there when I sold my
company two to three calm many of the
employees were from Europe this was you
know a few years back and it was
interesting they said Janice we love
this deal you were very happy with the
cash and our jobs and else but we don't
really want to handle options too
complicated we'd give them back and of
course these people now make made tons
of money but it was really interesting
but you had to explain it you know they
just will give it back very funny yeah
so maybe what we could do now is open it
up and again thank goodness we're in
this room which makes a conversation
possible I'll just start looking sort of
left to right and see we've got a
question in the back row please go ahead
I think a lot of us I realized that the
CEO if they hire better people in every
position inside a company I figured it
easier set that then you give us some
tactics to actually come with that yeah
yeah this is you you can start oh so
specifically you know what to look for
and you're put a little finer point the
question a few if you would now you go
out yeah I'm okay at marketing sales
finance mataji's cetera but right how
should I think about it are specifically
tackling how do I actually go out and
get the A+ pong player after the my
company can't be we heard a subtext
there which is so that the founder could
have a shot at staying CEO these are the
pieces of juicy
first off let me start with this I mean
Sequoia over the years has gotten a
little bit of grief I think incorrectly
for for firing founders to tell you the
truth and you know Michael knows a lot
of our companies that's actually really
not all that true and we really want to
find a founder who can be a CEO and turn
into Jensen and NVIDIA or Omar and AdMob
and a more recent story you know there
are there are many others so just I
wanted to put put that on the record
secondly I think you really have to
understand caucus with your advisers as
to what you're trying to accomplish if
this is an RD mission for the you know
for the next year you really need to
bring on marketing it sales I know it's
a lot of companies seem to okay I've got
a million bucks now let me go hire a
full team and you really need that but
as we talked about before I think it's
understand what your capabilities are
and project yourself out to the org
chart a year from now and then what will
you be doing and then hire somebody to
complement yourself I don't think it's
necessarily rocket science and I go back
to the point also hiring somebody that
fits into the culture don't look at the
resume you know look at look at the
person is this somebody who can grow
with the company I can work with who can
help me meet other people who can help
me recruit and then lastly recruiting
takes a ton of time people don't realize
that I tell a lot of our companies oh I
don't want to go spend a hundred
thousand dollars on me and as a former
recruiter you know I have a lot of
experience if you really need to recruit
an a person you either as a founder need
to devote probably a third of your time
seriously thirty year times you're
recruiting more you stomach the fee and
pay and E and if you really want to hire
an a person and still paid spend fifteen
eighty percent ago maybe it's no ayay
it's a lot of time and I think you also
have to to put your ego aside which I
know you know can be really hard but you
need to really think about m going
forward am I the best person to run this
company I mean being a CEO is an awesome
responsibility in in every way I mean
and everything that you say your
employees are going to you know take it
to heart you know
management is such a hard thing to do so
I think you know and I've seen lots of
success stories of founders making it
and I've seen some you know big battles
where you know the board wanted to take
a CEO and the CEO didn't want to leave
and I think you have to really think
about it and and really take it to heart
am I the best person to build this
company or do I need a partner to help
me do so well here's here's one other
thought and Janice you know this company
I'm referring to remain nameless for now
but there's a company that's doing this
new company that's doing green chemicals
so they take a raw material glucose in
this case and then future it will be
cellulose six and then they process that
into intermediate chemicals and so they
call it a renewable chemicals kind of
company so this scent founder actually
was the first to raise his hand about
two years ago and say hey you know I
think we need a chemical this is a
biotech PhD and says hey I need you to
go board and find me a CEO it's his idea
board goes out and finds the CEO CEO
comes in makes a pretty good impact but
at the end of the day had real ego
issues with the board and so that person
couldn't control his egos a big
personality and the founder really did
everything he could to empower that
person once he made that decision he had
faith he just got behind the person and
they had good experience together
ultimately the board fired the guy and
ends up putting the founder back into
this into the saddle that founder to
your direct point tactically what he did
is he okay I'm going to go off and I'm
going to build the office of the CEO and
he said what am I going to have on my
left hand I need a strong technology
person from this case the industrial
biotech space ends up keeping that
person engaged and his message to that
person who could go do his own company
who's a superstar in zone right he said
look I need you to be my partner I'm
going to have faith in you I'm going to
stay out of your day to day business I'm
not going to micromanage or I'm not
going to be paranoid about whether or
not you're getting your work done you
know you're getting it done and then
goes out to the commercial side we end
up hiring a former CEO of a pretty
significant business in that space and
convince that person to partner with
this founder they created the office the
CEO so thinking listening to the people
you want to hire
saying how can I make this work within
your life throw you some touchdown
passes uh we'll have a you know and this
is going to sound really corny but
appealing to people sort of passion and
personal interests and saying you know
you could go off and be the CEO of
something else or you could go up but
but get behind me on this thing will
work as a team and we really build a
company together and being honest about
that and then after the fact you close a
person delivering on that you hear have
that person run don't shoot at their
feet let him run or don't hire him in
the first place but that was I think
this guy was a great example if he's a
35 year old you know PhD with no
operating experiences turning out to be
a heck of a CEO just raised a bunch of
money about 40 million bucks in this
market at a very at a pretty solid
valuation was was really surprising to a
lot of people you know a couple of
points I would make there so first of
all you know you recognize this if you
find a company then you bring in you
know venture capital the dynamics of
running the company change obviously
you're giving up some control I think is
really important and you have a say in
this that you bring the right people you
know assuming you have a choice to
invest in your company build the right
board and so on and you know I don't
have a very open dialogue with that you
know say you have you know a small board
with your board about you know how
you're doing and and and and where you
need help and so on and I would echo Joe
that certainly it's very rewarding for
us as B C's to see a founder become the
CEO and be successful I mean it's just
it's phenomenal I mean obviously we all
like to make money and everything else
but seriously I mean it's very very
rewarding to see that to happen and you
know then you don't have some of this
tension along the way as well but also I
think you as a founder need to be and
you pointed this out but you need to be
very clear about not just what your
capabilities are in which stage of your
career you're at but also what you like
to do cuz often a Finder is more
interested in technology or being the
Evangelist than running the day-to-day
operations and you know I'm a big sort
of believer is still in you know Jim
Collins and his view that you need an
outside inside person I think teams can
be you know much more productive and
individual the other thing is running a
company is sort of
lonely job in many respects as you
change you know when you sort of handful
of you sort of building out a technology
it's one thing when you start to
organize it become and you have to at
some point there needs to be some
organization it starts to change and and
your job becomes very different so
really leverage the people who are
investing in your company you know we
don't have a human capital people what
we have pcs but you know people like Joe
now go and stick with them and really
sort of understand where you're good
where you're not so good how you can
grow is it time for me to be CEO now but
and if I continue along this path am I
going to have for the company or is
there someone I could bring in that
could really help me achieve what I want
for my company and then maybe next time
I'll be the CEO and there's things like
that to consider but also and you know
this is the best network in the world
right here in the valley which is why we
create these great companies you know
really leverage the people you know
other people who've done it before CEOs
your mentors you know we talk about this
all the time but you know many of the
people have been successful been able to
reach out to people they know what
people who know someone who knows
someone and and I would you know just do
that but you're having the the open
conversation so that you're not
surprised by the board and you know just
is really important and really develop
that relationship and you just be very
sort of clear about yourself and
everybody sort of thinks they want to be
the CEO and you talk a lot of to a lot
of company public company CEOs they say
my best job was actually the job before
this because this is all I had many an
opportunity today so you need to think
about that as well you know what what do
I really enjoy and then you know again
coming back to if you do bring in a CEO
you know there are professional CEOs and
they're fine but also bring in someone
who shares your passion particularly in
this industry in the tech industry you
know I've seen instances where bigger
come has brought in professionals and
they don't really like products and that
doesn't work you know so think about
that and I think Andy said something
really important which I've seen derail
companies over and over again don't
bring in really smart people to help you
and then don't give them any control or
autonomy to do that it's the worst thing
to be micromanaged and not have
the ability to innovate and make
decisions so just you know make sure
that from a personal perspective you're
ready to let go of some control before
you start bringing in a team and you
know this I don't think you will make
mistakes
oh absolutely you will absolutely trust
me you will
so it's coincidence that zach has his
hand up because I was gonna cold call
him now because he's the only one with
the name tag I can actually read which
to me is the international symbol for
please call on so so it's like the very
early stages of small service for some
people say achievement rotunda so I
don't even speak to have vassals
splitting a provision so I presume
against aging but what one brings
happily dearest relationship
because that video company is not even
accompanying and thinking about those
bright vision and you file something she
is it you want I'll throw out something
I've seen a lot of companies come guys
people come together and I've seen it
work and not work and founder dynamics I
asked Dan Norman over at one time what
was his ultimate secret to making
network appliance into a multi-billion
dollar companies number one thing he
said was not VCS wasn't it wasn't had
hunters wasn't anybody else it was I
engaged the founders and gave them a
role I mean meaningful role and you know
the Google founders are a great example
of sort of people that know each other
my one advice would be work together
before you give up the equity and before
you truly capitalize the company before
you form that true cap structure that
cap table to divide up the equity start
working together as though this is a
small project that small project becomes
hewlett-packard potentially you know
there's a couple people working in a
garage getting to know each other
understanding whether they can live in
the foxhole together think of it as like
a foxhole so battle out there and don't
be cynical is very intense out there as
you know once you get into the real
which your company becomes you know
visible and financed you've got all
kinds of new responsibilities are going
to mushroom out and making sure you're
in that foxhole with someone you can
trust and it shares your vision and
stylistically you're compatible it's
very intimate it's like dating before
you marry someone I mean it's very
similar so let's assume that they do
that and they do it really well is 50/50
the right answer what are they bringing
to the table yeah he's a negotiation I
think
yeah and I think it's obviously 5050 but
you know just back to your point this
getting to know each other you know
whether it's and you see it more now
actually with this sort of tryin vibe
from recruiting generally but really get
to know each other before you solidify
it and sometimes it can be your friend
sometimes not but don't I think the
friend thing you've got to be a little
delicate about that you know I think it
really needs to be someone who's going
to contribute that you can work with
similar visions but just you know play
it out a bit if I can before you before
you determine the capital structure and
one other point if you plan to raise a
venture round and it simply we have two
co-founders in the room one of our
companies right now we are very part of
my job we are very analytical about the
chemistry between the founders when we
work with them as part of the exercise
I'm sure you're the same thing it's
frequent where one person does all the
talking and somebody doesn't say
anything you can see the body language
between people so a very important point
with your your potential future
investors and it impacts how you decide
to invest right Joe
yeah go for service you'll find some
people when you're recruiting you're
very early on there want co-founder
status you need to be very careful about
that to your point like so co-founder
status tends to mean stop and control
all those types of things but really
think about it think about what this
person's going to contribute but you're
right go to spend time with them if
you've got say well
to try to make that process that's
possible SM project status will try to
design your letter big numbers more
seriously we want to answers extended
well thank about six months work
together three six months yeah I mean I
think you really have to know that
you're aligned in your vision you have
to know that you're aligned in your
values and you have to leave you know
what be very clear about what those
people are bringing to the table and you
genuinely have to like those people I
mean like Andy said you were in early
start of days as many of you many of you
know it is not pretty I mean it is very
hard and you it you know tough times and
you know people tend to be quite
emotional and lots of hard work and you
really have to like the people that and
respect the people that you're working
with so I think you know I couldn't say
X amount of time is the magic answer but
I think you should know I mean in your
gut you know everyone's very analytical
and I appreciate that but I think in
your gut if you have a doubt it's
probably not the right thing to do
yeah I mean if you think about it the
early stage it's not like you want a
trajectory an action orientated
trajectory you're actually thinking
about what this company can be there's
lots of dialogue and lots of
brainstorming so really is you know
being able to work with that person then
you'll be able to make decisions from
that because there comes a point where
you know you can brainstorm forever and
not get anywhere so you know it's going
to be someone that you can really sort
of evolve and build something from so
you know those relationships when they
work you know Google whatever a really
fabulous you know there's there's lots
of tales where it gets a little tense
along the way one last idea check the
other person out do your homework oh
yeah come up with your own references
and say to that person we're gonna go
form this company we're going to divide
equity let's make sure we really know
each other and we'll do it in the spirit
of understanding each other so do
references contextually check that
person out say hey who've worked with
you in the past and let me give you some
of my references and you have them
written down here you go and it's if
that's a little bit of an awkward
conversation potentially but I think it
warrants because you may find out the
person's going through a messy divorce
has a you know eight duis their name or
something you know I think seriously
there are some people that look graves
is the target not all right
I've done cruising stints you know who
knows it you it's so really doing the
homework on who that person is behind
there yeah we find the persona is an
important step and I sometimes have you
know I have a group of people that I've
worked with I really trust I sometimes
have those people meet people that I'm
going to work closely with to say just
go have a meal together and just give me
you know because people tend to get
enamored with one another you know quite
quickly and then you realize maybe it is
going to work or not so I sometimes let
somebody I really trust have a meal with
the person say what do you think you
know give me your perspective so last
row guy in the white shirt so maybe
humans means cable Aundre popping up so
really really safe with hats and
founders being about bringing on more
people how do you divide the amount
compensation between equity and very
small amounts of capital that you may
have personally so very small I'm sorry
how do you think about sort of that does
if you're in the market that you think
may be winner-take-all and you have to
move fast are you looking at the ratio
between you look at the correlation to
in cash in equity yeah yeah exactly so
how do you like that if you're trying to
find people who are automatically
awesome but you may need to like
encourage and stuff and specifically if
you give the interns equity don't do it
don't do it don't don't ever give you
equity to people who aren't going to be
long-term contributors to company okay
like I said there's only so much to go
around including executive recruiters
well we have suggested we actually about
90% of our searches we do get options to
invest in the company otherwise there's
no reason
really carry cap cables brooder what is
what you mean well yes yes that tables
involved I think earlier on you know
you're putting it coming together you
probably not have anything eyes yeah I
mean Facebook early days I mean that's
what they had to do you know to get to
get people but I think you know it
depends on how much capital you have I
mean it's hard to find people in the
valley right now unless they're really
junior that are going to take a job with
very little cash because I think you
know like Deanna said kind of the the
days of big liquidity people potentially
see they are gone so I think you have to
be really careful about who you're
looking to hire and be really clear
about here's what we can offer for now
but you know if we raised around you
know you have to really look at changing
things you know when I when I came on to
Facebook one of the first things I did
when I got there after a rounded been
raised and things run a much better
cash perspective we had two real 'evil a
vet II in realign everybody's calm you
know people had taken very small cash
comp and we fixed that for everybody
because that was the right thing to do
and so I think that's you know that's
something that you would have to think
about doing but it will be a little bit
of a challenge I think I would also
suggest by the way that you pay
yourselves little as pave Indian Jenner
I and in fact some of your first
employees might make more than you as
the founder a great particularly if you
need to hire some with little bit
experience who has a mortgage to pay etc
we see a lot of companies they do their
you know 2 million dollar a round and
then we want to make you know hundred
seventy-five thousand dollars in the
world doesn't work that way I could not
agree more I mean I think as an early
employee has started it's a huge turnoff
you know when you're when executives
make so much more than then
rank-and-file people I think there
should be just a lot of compression and
comp in early startups what's known as
you say as you build you level up a
level what
now your honor can you talk a little bit
tactically how to create this long term
alignment with your early employees is
that through like vesting equity and for
withholding equity and how long would
you have that best three years for your
community wanting in a formidable core
minimum I agree with that yeah I think
that you know in terms of alignment
obviously different jobs would have
different compensation at some point and
different sub equity levels but you you
do align through you know fairness
really you know you pay for contribution
I'm really a big believer in sounds an
obvious thing to say but it's not always
a case paying for performance so that's
really key but in order to pay for
performance you have to measure that
performance right so that's really
something that's the way of aligning
people so that they believe that they
are being paid for their performance as
you as you go through and I know it
tends to sound sort of very sort of you
know heavy in terms of worker but it's
some point you have to do that I think
the key thing is that I personally
believe you know some people try and
adapt by changing vesting schedules and
different things like that for different
people I'm really not a fan of that I
think there's certain things like
vesting schedules were stopped that
should be consistent now you know in any
situation they're always going to be
exceptions to rules but generally I
think you start going down the path of
offering different people different
conditions beyond you know some sort of
structure for pay and performance and I
think it's very difficult and this could
be an area to where having a good
relationship with other entrepreneurs or
legal counsel can help because there's a
lot of stuff that's market and you can
simplify radically the process of
building the team by just adopting
what's market and just as an example the
one-year cliff with a four year vest is
essentially market in Silicon Valley all
right so that can that can just save a
whole lot of time in trouble by just
adopting market practices wherever
possible yeah you know and we don't tend
to like to talk too much about lawyers
right but you know actually and having
there are some great there are seriously
some great lawyers in this vise and
great counsel and you know him talk
about them advising but there's some
really good people
we work with you well to set up the
right structure for your company and
give you the right advice early on and
you know the is the legal counsel that
they tend to be on multiple boards at
different stages and they have partners
or multiple boards at different stages
and so they really can help you in terms
of you know what's you know market and
what a best practices
what's work what's not and I think in
terms of driving alignment I mean
certainly compensation is one part of it
but there's so much more to that right
I'm so much more let's come back on this
side and see I have a left-hand bias so
I want to be aware Alex sure this
question is wrong to two mothers but I'm
an MBA student so when I'm ready to
graduate I'm going to have a good amount
of loans also have some cash I can pay
off a big percentage of those loans I
also can use that cash to invest it
if I uh so my company paid interest
about the pit interest I'm gonna have to
get a higher salary we needed suze orman
on this man like I know what she would
say because I watch the show every night
so that's right no no what'd she say
so if Suzy were here okay listen
that was a bad Suzy Orman impression so
the student loans are probably at
extraordinarily low interest rates with
extremely flexible pay back if you've
got a choice between paying off a really
low interest loan and perhaps investing
in or living off of your savings which
probably has a higher return rate it
think about it that way and it becomes a
little easier to decide to just pay the
minimums on those let those out there
you see a lot of people letting student
loans go to full maturity before they
pay them back because the terms and
minute rates are so flexible or so so
advantageous it really is kind of like a
marginal what do I do with that last
dollar what's the highest return for
that dollar it's probably feeding you
and keeping you going on your
entrepreneurial venture rather than
paying the the loans back early that's
what Suzy would say and I guess I
believe that - because I just paid my
last student loan off about five years
ago
that means I'll put any money in my
business and so I'm going to present
your Fester's and so what do you put in
i disagree which is you're putting your
life into your is nothing and if you do
the opportunity cost of your time I mean
you could leave here tomorrow I mean no
offense by picking this number but
probably make hundreds of thousands of
dollars next year if you took a boring
job at some consulting firm you know but
you but but instead you're going to
actually plowing that resource which
society values I don't know again in the
hundreds of thousand dollars no offense
maybe it's millions for you but but into
your business that's free contribution
of huge value you should count that
sorry this is your bill pay raise might
figure having two founders are how you
want to hire your first few more you I
didn't think about it
earlier that common times equal it
before time we're really good they can
start their own thing how do you
reconcile that with both you go and also
the faculty question I don't think it's
a magic answer for that one it's it's
difficult and it's again recruiting is
really really hard and we spend a ton of
time on that particular point but I
think you you use your board if you have
a board to help explain that this is an
important company and that the role will
be critical and there's great experience
and you use whatever tools you have but
it's it's really really difficult but
you will need to be careful back to an
earlier point not to cave on that first
hire and give away five points because
it just creates so many problems down
down the road but I wish I had a magic
answer for you well here's one thought
keep it to yourself what you're doing as
long as you can if what you want to do
is really interesting and impactful
protect it as well as you can you want
to guard that secret and generally
listen more than you're selling I hear a
lot of excitement about starting the
company and you almost feel like there's
this vibe of I can't wait to bring other
people involved that's wonderful but be
careful what you're asking for that and
I'm not saying like I said to be cynical
and you want to be on the other side too
trusting but I've seen a lot of
entrepreneurs hang around other
entrepreneurs and then all of a sudden
get three companies that all look
exactly the same as opposed to one that
was ready to break out consume sank so
be careful about I would say try and get
yourself position so that you have an
unfair advantage early on and maybe some
strategic component to your business
whether it's a patent that you file or
get some action on or some strategic
money or a key you know active chairman
or something like that some industry
veteran it's your associate with
whatever it is that the other people say
you know what it's probably better to go
with you and be part of your team than
to compete with you right and that's so
make sure you have your ducks in order
before you really let out even to
anybody what's your to really try to do
it's a great question and a bit of a
personal choice as to how you tackle
that I'd love to go back to the canned
questions because we had one that was
pretty interesting that no one's brought
up yet if the success rate of hiring is
50/50 on those first few non founder
hires how do you decide I'm gonna fire
you here's how I'm going to fire you and
here's how we're going to like recover
from that how do you work through that I
mean I unfortunately had to do that a
lot and it's it's a very painful thing
to do and I think you have to be really
sure that it's the right thing to do you
have to be very clear that you know you
have held up your end of the bargain
in that relationship but it's sometimes
it's just not going to be you know
either it wasn't the right the right job
you know it wasn't the right culture fit
for whatever reason sometimes it's just
not going to work and I think when you
know that that's the right thing to do
you have to act swiftly I think if
somebody doesn't fit it can really make
a big problem within your company how to
do it gracefully and respectfully that's
all I can can say about how to do it
it's hard it's going to be one of the
hardest things you'll doing in your
career but you have to make sure that
you treat people with respect when you
do that unless they've done something
when I say illegal or immoral you own
50% of that failure you know when you
hire somebody that doesn't work you
cannot blame that on solely on that
person that's your deal as well so make
sure that you work out a way that you
know people go go away as gracefully as
possible but act act swiftly yeah I was
just going to say a small point there
and also be generous when you accept
somebody's been there 11 months you know
give them their that spliff don't go
crazy but it's a small world and it's
such a connected world a people will
find out that so I'll just be generous
that's a great point that Joe may know I
think that's really key some people
trying nickel-and-dime it you just got
to think about the big picture here and
it's a small world you know a small
valley you know a couple of things I
would say when you're recruiting and
things that might lead to this this type
of decision is that you know I've worked
for large companies work for small
companies startups and invest in
startups and you know one of the things
that you do have when you're involved in
a large company and you have maybe a big
department a big organization you have
the opportunity to nurse your people and
to grow them in an early-stage company
you don't have that luxury you need
people are going to come in and be
effective and so sometimes you see
people who don't quite fit you think
well you know I can help them well you
won't be able to help them because you
won't have the time they have to perform
and the other thing is you know you're
seeing someone is not performing you can
be assured that your team is also seeing
that so to your point if you let it sort
of linger then it just becomes a bad
situation for everybody actually but I
think how you do it it's as important as
you know when you do it and doing it
it's it's a tough situation but doing
you know sometimes gonna have to let
people go and just do it well okay yes
in the back row yeah
a lot of sweat equity and he has silent
partners and save all the best attached
but basically all the cash going to cut
product development and marketing
centers there's no boats get mcsalley
right now so question is should keep you
looking at try to is negotiate they
Savannah fine Western a structure kind
of locate a higher portion of the equity
or should be looking at more from a
perspective of he's already made a good
salary basically sitting salary so that
doesn't get paid for all the I guess
longer grab all do you really want to
write a big check as soon as you've got
in finance that's a liability to your
end investors will say what I or this
person for her granted back pay good for
that is really amazing meeting more so
the company is actually profitable and
making money bringing cash they're not
even get I guess getting salary high
salaries out of the checklist
minimize the liabilities on your balance
sheet that's a liability it's a future
payment it's a balloon payment
I recommend getting them just a little
bit more equity yeah
what's the curious about the silent
partner business what can you say a
little bit more about that and why did
they come into the picture I think
sometimes this pops up on cap tables and
it's interesting thing to pause on and
talk about so he's oversized and
therefore thing is that that I
understood or they they're not police as
if they were a check and they've
disappeared on to do the you know they
keep up they have calls etc but they're
not in the country in which the business
is running so they viously they've
invested money they know in perspective
they have sessions but they're not
that's all we do so he's one of
essentially building the company and
that's how what advice and other advice
would you have for managing a situation
like that where early almost angel /
advisors are are on the cap table well
you're not drawing a salary right so you
get shared you know you have a shared
sort of sweat equity is Joe was saying
earlier I don't see a reason to accrue
cash I think if they're interested in
this thing they're already working for
the equity I'm sorry I don't think any
more yeah yeah I mean I think there is
some investment in terms of sweat equity
work right that you're making you know
what spelled the company so you can't
backtrack on that let's go right here
what are your stuff your thoughts on
hiring offshore everything money's tight
pretty careful be very careful I mean I
I have I don't have any well that's not
true I have maybe just one or two
examples where I've seen it work really
well I think often times you think it's
going to save you money and it ends up
not I think you know from an engineering
perspective where I've seen at work is a
you know a lot of due diligence done
upfront about where it's going to go and
then very specific pieces of work that
are being done but it takes lots of
management oversight
takes lots of communication at all hours
of the day so I think just really make
sure that it's going to give you what
you want before you get into that can be
very complex the only time I've seen it
work is when one of the founders is
actually in that geography I for a
period of time but I agree with
everything Beth said yeah I mean we had
a company I was at ColdFusion 1 which
probably most of you don't remember but
it we spent 10 million dollars on
advertising before we had revenue or a
real product so it was a quite
interesting time in the valley and we
ended up buying a very small company in
Tallinn Estonia and this was like in
1999 which was quite before it's time to
go to Eastern Europe and it actually
worked really really well but we had a
the head of engineering ended up going
there it was very specific that they
were doing QA but that's about the only
time that I've ever seen it really work
well and actually save money yeah I
think Joe's point is really key I think
this companies grow what I'm seeing with
some of my companies they are working
with you're probably more consulting
entities in those countries to do
specific right work so it might be you
know in the mobile world might be
porting or throwing software or
something or you know that you know
depending on whether it's India Russia
wherever it's certain sort of pools of
talent software talent for example that
you can leverage but you have to
structure it and it has to be defined
otherwise it's and for very early-stage
country it's it's hard let's go right
behind you yep no I'm sorry you yeah
technology I to this exclusion if you
wait too long to discuss the cap table
then the technology person might start
wanting more like 50/50 but if you
discussing earlier that
hold out as long as you can yeah about
that I mean I think you have to be you
have to be careful about that though
because you don't want to destroy trust
with with these people that you're
working with so I think for me it would
depend on how far along the path you are
what the relationship is what is your
level of certainty that this is actually
going to work out how important that
person is going to be to the long-term
success of the company all good points
yes sir sometimes that's what I believe
you're talking about a little bit might
be true equity as opposed to the best
game plan I'd like you to talk a little
bit about that particularly your king if
your tactical side counterpart has
actually developed some of your IP
already and you both raised money
bearish to your difference between the
equity do I need work to perhaps more to
the part than the best I've never had
that chance why you think founder stock
versus investing equity yeah I think so
but it was still best yeah everything I
did everything that so you're not just
going to say hey this is it you can cash
out tomorrow you're not purchasing at
that point I think the company's
evolution that's the thing you're not
purchasing you want people involved who
are going to continue to stay because
you know in an early-stage company you
have IP and nobody - nobody else I mean
that's what are going to do with it so I
think that you need to get people
aligned by you know allocating stock
appropriately for you know work and
maybe IP and it's an interesting
situation but you know you need that
needs to vest that you're all aligned
going forward and you know you're
actually you're working for the company
it sounds like maybe one way to knit
these two scenarios is that the
technical contributions in the form of
software or hardware or expertise has to
be on the ledger of things that you're
tallying up when you say ok how are we
going to divide this up okay I've been
working on it for six months but I'm
just an MBA you've been here 30 days
built this fabulous application how do
we wait those two things and and and the
reason these partnerships blow up is
typically because of simple things like
communication people don't actually get
a chance to say out loud what their
underlying interest is or what their
underlying goals and ambitions are and
if you have that conversation and you've
got that chemistry that these guys
talked about a lot of times those things
kind of magically merge and you come out
with an answer that's like oh yeah
that's cool we sign me up and it works
out a lot easier you're gonna have
different roles you know you might bring
the IP and you're gonna continue working
on that and you're gonna go out and
bring people and money into the business
and you know but this you gotta be
talking communicating spending time
together all those things understanding
oh I mean I I'm a huge fan of
transparency I mean I just think if you
are holding something back with someone
that you're really relying on it's gonna
cause problems so so yeah let's come
back on this side so it's a really
really useful
what specifically very granular level
how you go about contact if you want
like LinkedIn that you want to target
how you go about finding people on
Craigslist how you mind a network by
quite specific I'm talking about wording
and strategy about how to find those
people that you might if you have a
specific position in mind because it
might be good to have a hard core and
you granted it with something that's
local here a tarpaulin faster with okay
so somebody would be either at EPO level
or no senior development level and we
found that to be how many more people
than I would have thought to do until
about yes so yeah great question we've
we've actually used social networking as
a tool it is a component of what we
actually do and the best way to do is to
subscribe to the what is it the
corporate edition of LinkedIn so there's
a corporate edition okay for less
expensive one please shave the support
for what about that's why your company
never seriously the the LinkedIn I
wouldn't do Craigslist you're going to
get you end up spending the next six
months of your time filtering through
eight million resumes that don't make
any sense but I would say do the keyword
searches of LinkedIn think about the
companies from which you want to draw
the gene pool talent so if you're a
developer then what kind of developers
is an infrastructure software companies
at a web developing couple you what is
your category and then think about pee
my zebra then we're also the other zebra
is hanging out where they what watering
holes are they are they living nearby
and thinking about the best companies in
that space and then I would do keyword
searches for those companies and the
keyword searches for the skill sets
you're looking for that will pop a bunch
of names and then what you do is you
send them in mail so you can do it in
mail and it's only 25 bucks a month per
user and it's not much and I think the
corporatization is only like 250 bucks a
year and so on I think Joe brought some
coupons yeah
free 30-day trial that that was what
idea what idea is pop the very precise
be trying to be precise the people are
gonna bring the domain expertise the
technical expertise that you really want
right now and the more surgical you are
in that process the better like there
may be there's there are companies in
there universities in Romania and in
Ukraine and in Russia that are all you
know computer science centers of
excellence and they've got you know
development companies the only the real
issue in the real risk point there's
obviously how do you protect your IP
because you don't know but one last
thing I'm going to say that your earlier
point is go sorry you go to the place
you're going to recruit don't don't
don't don't do this by phone you got to
travel there and it's a lot to 18 hour
or 24 hour deal to get to the romanian
places like that you got to get on the
ground go meet these people spend time
with them don't try and do it all
remotely to this right so I've heard a
little discussion I want to crystallize
it around
work on finish your example something
continues really hard problems they were
devout now articulate a very simple
business
the CEO
what is that dialogue around very
transparent very trusting open well you
know you've got IP got an asset and you
want to commercialize it right so you're
gonna have to find assuming you can't do
it on your own either financially or
because of skills so you have to sort of
be very clear with your own with
yourself you know about you know how
you're going to do this what you're
prepared to give up in a way in order to
achieve you know the opportunity of
building a company along the way
you know nobody's going to come to you
and say hey you know I don't think I
mean if you wanted to sell something you
go somewhere to sell it right but you're
wanting to build a company so you've got
to share in that company going forward
so you're not going to get paid for ten
years of hours worked but you know it's
a negotiation with the people you bring
in and and again you know you have to
bring in people you trust you can
triangulate with people you know and you
have to sit down you have to it's
negotiating and knew yourself I mean the
end of the day it's your decision to
decide I'm gonna I want to go for this
opportunity to build this company
because if you've got IP you go and sell
at someone but I don't I want to build a
company so you're going to have to think
really clearly and again talk to so many
of the people that you you know you know
it can be introduced it with this
fabulous network you have and sort of
okay in order to do this what has been
done before what is reasonable and then
you know you negotiate with the people
you want to work with and then you have
to sort of it really is your decision in
a way you know okay so I'm going to give
up this much of equities are bringing
this person who I believe can build a
company with me and I've got to feel
good about that decision because it may
work it may not but I'm not going to get
paid for that ten years unless it works
but this is a way I choose to go forward
and you know it takes courage right it
takes the right partnership otherwise go
and sell the IP to Hewlett Packard or
whoever it is depending on who you know
great point let's go here
situation where this is my situation
founder and I put the money into the LLC
got everything around me and customers
etc you know in my employers at Cooley
say I should still have a vesting
schedule and I guess I refused because
it's my money you see what he comes in
now should I
because you're gonna provide the future
no it's it's you're going forward to
build a company together so you need to
be aligned going forward past is past I
have seen founders sell some of their
stock in an area and take some liquidity
they say think the VCS will say I'll
give you a little bit to take from risk
off the table so you're not worrying
about paying your mortgage and I'm not
going to buy your equity as what is your
motivation it goes out the door with the
stock you just sold but recognize their
implications with that two big
implications with your common share
price so that's something to be really
wary of think about what happens you
doing this right and I actually want to
assure you I've never seen it now the
part that's in a highly negotiable is
what's the part of your previous vesting
that you'll get credit for as of the
financing so it's not going to go back
to zero but it's not also going to be
fully vested so think about that as one
of the variables that a founder gets to
negotiate with with with investors yes
sir when you're
compensation packages for many different
roles you're going to hire during the
medical Penn State was a financing see
exactly being and so forth what's the
best way for someone to find out our
market rates what every student so you
know if I'm trying to hire someone and
saying okay I basis points and I think
there's making all my friends he's a CTO
this guy's dentist he's the CTO he's
getting 5% pay you know it's a really
big jump and it's hard to say you know
come on board this is a really great
deal I should on giving giving face
because I love deal what's the best way
to find these markets it's really hard I
mean I think there's there's no hard and
fast rules to equity out there
unfortunately I mean I think I would
really rely on your VCS and your
attorneys to give you what what they've
seen and I think you know what I've
experienced is people don't understand
equity at all to Michael's point I mean
people will come into Facebook and and
you know it is an engineer and say I
want you know 2% I'm like well just
never going to happen like it's just not
going to happen so they didn't they
didn't understand you know they really
did not understand what it could mean so
I think you have to make sure that you
can articulate kind of the you know what
the play is what you see the company
doing the challenge of the work and
where you know what this would mean for
them because I think people just don't
understand and then use you know use
your partners to try to get data
there's no published tool that I know of
that can tell you what to give them
now one thing I will tell you from
experience it's it's so a company grows
and early on you tend to have lots of
conversation about percentages as the
company grows you to get off the
presentations that's what you're really
talking about the number of shares and
the value that's right you can accrue
from those shares over time if the
company is successful so you know if
you're a little ways down the road new
social percent risk it's very difficult
cuz it's sort of it's really hard
because people you know they have these
percentages but they're not necessary
relating to the stage of the company
right so you just get off that and you
talk about you know numbers of shares
and there are benchmarks out there you
know but you have what he view is often
because if you want a superstar
you'll tend to compensate for a
superstar but there is benchmarking you
know formal and informal formal there's
lots of studies informal through venture
capital firms and we do our own
independent studies as well we obviously
talk to each other and you normally have
two or more around the board so you'll
get that dialogue as well but the other
thing is you know 2% of something is
better than 10% of nothing so you really
need to articulate the value of your
company - right and how you're going to
build that company so it's not just
about the percentage it's about the
value you're going to create in a vision
and you know you can argue you mean you
really want someone who obviously wants
to be compensated fairly but also
someone who's buying into what you're
trying to create so that they will have
some share of that going forward - it's
not just about the percentage in
isolation of what you're trying to do
okay one minute last question it's
really waiting for focus and create a
structure around
the Terry stop abbreviation writes basic
trying to use them and to compensation
rule just luggage about their some of
that they were created restructuring
whether or not don't be that creative
yeah it's not like maybe she had stupid
said HEPA simple soup anyone edit - I
think it was vets earlier point parody
everybody's should have the same stock
option plan if establish the stock
option plan that is the documentation
don't anybody want off it or customize
it cuz you know it had end up with a you
know a basket of stuff you can't even
understand you spend all your time doing
contracts for people one plan every
employee give this creativity complexity
thing a complex t out creativity focus
on the business not the contractor ego
and a great note to end on thank our
panelists for coming today
thanks everybody